[Music]
little baby brought protest star to the
Grammys on Sunday with a powerful
performance of his song the bigger
picture
the performance kicked off when two
white police officers approached a black
driver played by Kendrick Sampson they
attempted to detain him before opening
fire on the unarmed man when he
attempted to run as the song carried on
real life activist Tamika Mallory
delivered an impassioned plea for
support and institutional change it's a
state of emergency it's been a hell of a
year hell for over 400 years my people
it's time we stand it's time we demand
the freedom that this land promises in a
statement released after his performance
little baby explained to that performing
that song meant the most to him I paint
pictures with my songs and wanted the
performance to bring that picture to
life just like with the song this
performance had to reflect the real no
sugar coating my family my fans and my
city know who I did this for what does
it mean tonight to be here and what what
is this moment like for you it's an
honor to be a part of music's biggest
night as well as to honor the movement
of Liberation and you know that we've
been fighting so hard for yeah Kendrick
opened up to E.T about the performance
before he hit the stage with little baby
what's it going to be like when you hit
that stage tonight you know what I'm
more interested than anything is how
people are going to react I just really
really yeah really yeah once you do the
work and go I just want to see if people
will react uh positively well if they
feel
um moved by it if it adds to a shift in
uh culture toward in the right direction
towards Liberation more art that honors
Liberation and the movement but little
baby wasn't the only artist to open up
about the movement at the 2021 Grammys
Big Sean Janae Ico and her who won song
of the year for her track I can't
breathe spoke out too but remember
um we we are the change that we wish to
see and you know that that that fight
that we had in us the summer of 2020
keep that same energy because we wrote
this song out of pain we wrote the song
out of hope we wrote this song thinking
that you know
um
we want things to change this song has
been a soundtrack to some people's March
when they were out there protesting the
lives of people that we've lost you know
um
it just it's I can't even I don't have
words for that feeling you know it means
so much to me and we still have a lot of
work to do prior to the show E.T caught
up with the recording Academy's interim
president who said inclusivity and
representation was top of mind I think
the Grammys are always trying to change
we're trying to evolve and since I've
been here for the short period that I
have which is a year I think we've made
huge strides and we'll continue to but
we want to be the most relevant and the
most respectful most inclusive
organization that really really
represents the craft and the Excellence
around music making so hopefully we'll
see more progress that's my goal and
after a little baby's performance he
told E.T it took a lot of work to pull
it off how did you all pull off the
little baby performance in multiple sets
everybody around different places it was
a lot of work actually it was
choreographed beat for beat for beat it
was just right outside the convention
center right there on on the street and
it was just a lot of work a lot of
planning a lot of rehearsing and uh to
nail it
foreign